optimizing the content the world has
really changed with content optimization
a lot of the things that used to work
two years ago three years ago even six
months ago are not working anymore the
world has really changed optimizing your
content so a lot of the things that
people are still saying of how to
optimize your content just don't matter
anymore so the description description
of your videos the caption on your
Instagram the caption on your tick tocks
Etc they don't matter for ranking they
might matter for the person watching the
video right they might read the caption
on your Instagram or your Tick Tock but
it doesn't matter for optimizing the
content
and so it used to be hey put your
keywords into your description and you
have a higher chance of ranking that
doesn't work anymore so it doesn't mean
don't have descriptions but spend very
little time on them it's not how your
content is not
losing because you don't have good
descriptions
same thing for putting in captions
so this is Rev it's a great service if
you ever need to caption your videos
rev.com is an awesome service they
charge a dollar per minute to do it with
a human or I think 10 cents a minute to
do it automatic if you want robots to
transcribe your text
the idea with this says hey if you put
it up on your YouTube videos for example
it's going to rank higher because it'll
show up in in Search and people know
what keywords you're using it we tested
700 something videos could improve that
it made any difference
so we want to be thinking optimizing the
content for the person watching does
having a caption audit increase the
watch time and their experience but if
it's just for ranking it doesn't make
any difference
tags are going to zero tags are already
zero on YouTube
they're going to zero on Instagram
they're going to zero on Tick Tock tags
are just not important anymore
that doesn't mean have zero tags but
they're if your content is not again
you're not losing because you don't have
the right tags on the content
if you look at well YouTube has been
dead for a long time so any of the
software or the or the tools that tell
you about optimizing your tags don't
even worry about it but if you look at
your own Instagram and you look at your
own Tick Tock and you see
uh Instagram will show you how many
views you're getting from tags and it
just it's dropping it's just not how
people are consuming people are not
consuming the content anymore through
tags can you get a few of you sure but
it's not really where most of the
consumption is happening so it's not
where we want to be spending our time
optimizing our content uh hashtags yeah
meta tags hashtags tags all the same
thing
likes don't matter
asking people to like your video doesn't
matter asking people to Heart your video
doesn't matter the the engagement metric
doesn't matter you're not again winning
because you don't have uh a lot of likes
on your video
it's not causal what I mean by that is
getting more likes on a video doesn't
lead to more views on a video getting
more hearts on your Instagram posts
doesn't lead to you getting more views
on an Instagram post same thing for tick
tock same thing from for all the
platforms it's a trailing indicator
meaning they they a lot of people watch
the video and so then you'll get some
people who like it but getting lots of
likes doesn't lead to people watching
more of the content and same thing for
comments
getting a lot of comments doesn't mean
the videos are going to take off or the
post is going to take off it's really
can you keep people's attention on the
post and so when you're asking for likes
and comments I would switch it to
focusing on how do I create better
content that's engaging naturally
the one thing that still does matter is
titles for YouTube titles for YouTube
still matters all the other stuff
description captions tags likes comments
do not matter uh but titles for YouTube
does matter because it allows you to
rank against other people's videos that
have a similar theme title
you know the optimizing the content like
that doesn't matter what actually
matters well winning the click and
holding attention for every platform the
thing that they care the most about in
the world is can you keep people on our
platform
everybody's moving towards can you get
people to watch your thing and can you
hold their attention
win the click watch the thing and hold
their attention
Instagram just did a huge update that
they reversed that they rolled back
because of a lot of people freaking out
but that's where they're moving
Tick Tock has has dominated the
conversation and I'd still Focus my
content more on Tick Tock than Instagram
we talked about that uh you know a
couple months ago if you want to get
exposure Tick Tock is for short form the
place the place to be and it's much more
about how much can you keep the person's
attention on your video and less about
engagement metrics and less about
whether they even follow you or not and
so that's the direction that everybody's
moving
uh Instagram wanted to move there
quickly they got a lot of negative
feedback so they're moving there slowly
but it's happening okay so can you get
people to watch your thing and can you
get people to stay on your thing that's
all that matters that's that is the most
that is 95 of ranking and your content
get noticed across every platform right
now
uh but yeah 90 95 of how you're going to
rank is can you win the click and can
you hold attention and not about all of
the keywords and optimization so I'm
going to focus most of today on Tick
Tock and YouTube mostly because YouTube
is long-form Tick Tock is the best short
form these are the best two places to be
but about Instagram Instagram is
basically the same as Tick Tock just a
smaller version of it now Instagram is
great for stories Instagram is great for
dming for messaging people for talking
to people that's where that's why we
want to be on Instagram but they get the
content out it's tick tock and YouTube
uh Tick Tock is a lot more forgiving so
you can post a lot more of all of the
platforms Tick Tock and Twitter are the
most forgiving so you can post you can
post air quotes junk you can post junk
if you want it doesn't it's not going to
really impact how well your account does
and then take the best the strategy
should be take the best tick tocks that
you create and then post Instagram less
frequent on Instagram more frequent Tick
Tock take the winners from Tick Tock and
post them on Instagram
so how do we win the click so Tick Tock
there is no click
uh Tick Tock is is basically only about
getting people to watch
people can click on your profile and
they can click on some hashtags but most
of the views on the videos will happen
from the for you page which is the for
you page is basically the home page so
the experience in Tick Tock is you load
up the app you see videos and then you
scroll and swipe and swipe and swipe and
swipe and swipe and just see more videos
that's where the consumption happens so
there is no click-through rate same
thing for YouTube Shorts YouTube shorts
there is no click-through rate
so we don't have to worry about
thumbnails it's only about the retention
uh Jessica and Brian are saying so
Gamers and Geeks are still leaving
Instagram should I focused on Tick Tock
and Twitter Tick Tock Twitter uh and
Discord are for gamers the best part
about Instagram is you can direct
message people well you can't do that on
Tick Tock they have to be you have to
follow each other to to be able to
message each other on Tick Tock but in
Instagram you can direct message so for
communication Tick Tock is still great
but the strategy would be take your best
content from Tick Tock and bring it over
to Instagram
um even on Instagram when you're
scrolling most of the consumption
happens not from somebody searching for
a hashtag and not from somebody going to
your profile it comes from people
scrolling from the Instagram homepage
right that's what people are they upload
the app and they just start scrolling
think about your own use that's how most
of most of where your consumption
happens as well and so there is no real
click-through rate
YouTube though it does matter
YouTube though it does matter and so
with YouTube what does a good
click-through rate look like it really
depends on how many Impressions that
your videos are getting and So for
anybody who's doing YouTube here uh you
know Glenn shared some of his wins and
lost Curry I know shared some of his
wins inside Discord
what is a good click-through rate looks
like well it depends on how many
Impressions a video is getting
and so what we'd like to do internally
and for all the channels that we work on
and worked on some of the biggest
channels in the world inside of personal
development entrepreneurship that
leadership Etc is if you go to your
analytics tab
and you click on the see more and sort
by impressions
this YouTube analytics is is a giant
treasure Trove of information but it can
be overwhelming this is the one page you
have to pay attention to
why because if you can change your title
and change your thumbnail
on a video that took you however many
hours to make changing the title
changing a thumbnail might take a few
minutes but can have outsized returns
dramatic improvements and increases in
how well your video does
so what you look at is if you sort by
Impressions this is how many times
YouTube is trying to promote this video
so this video here I don't know which
video this is but YouTube tried to
promote it 161 million times on my
channel
YouTube tried to promote this video 161
million times
overall they tried to promote my videos
3.7 billion times that's a lot of it's a
lot of impressions
so it's unfair to compare videos that
are having 100 million impressions
versus one is having 20 million
impressions or a hundred thousand
Impressions versus 20 000 Impressions or
ten thousand Impressions versus 200
Impressions right I mean you could just
take off some zeros and make it apply
uh last curious as you're looking at 90
days or 28 usually 90 days so you have
options here you can go 28 days 90 days
last 365. 90 days is usually a pretty
good Benchmark to say this is what
YouTube is trying to promote right now
this is low hanging fruit we often Focus
so much in making new videos where
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit where
whenever I get into somebody's channels
usually the first thing I look at
instead of telling them to make more
videos and make better content that's a
harder conversation hats hey you already
have some low-hanging fruit let's go fix
those videos first
super exciting topic today the the
official name was systems for
organization what app Services
subscriptions and memberships help you
manage platforms and content efficiently
I'm going to switch that down to just
systems and tools make it a little bit
easier for everybody to uh to follow
along so we're going to talk about
hiring so my favorite place to hire is
upwork
when I first started my business I
thought I need to have everybody uh
local everybody in an office and I
realized that one my team wanted to
travel and move around and I did too and
so I started exploring different ways to
be able to do things remotely
upwork used to be
odesk which is what I got started on and
then moved to upwork and it's just a
fantastic way to find people from around
the world to be able to help you build
and grow your business and people work
from their home or from a coffee shop or
wherever they want to work from and uh
you can you know post a job ad and I
could make an entire training if you
guys are interested in how to hire
properly
through upwork but through any job
recruitment site because most people I
think higher incorrectly and you end up
stuck with somebody who's just okay as
opposed to actually getting great talent
so if you've connected with Yelena which
you all have at some point you know we
found Yelena actually found her
are we saying boyfriend or fiance on
upwork and we hired him and he started
working with us and then we had more
work to do and he suggested his his
girlfriend yelling at so we brought
Yellen on board and yelling I started
just doing uh
administrative work behind the scenes
and then we said hey we'd love to bring
you into movement makers and our YouTube
growth boot camp and be involved more
public facing responding responding to
our customers because you're so warm and
kind and personable and friendly and uh
got a big heart and so let let's try
this it's too too much to go through in
like in a couple minutes right now but
we can do an entire presentation on how
to hire properly and upwork I'll give a
super quick summary you start with
making a really
ugly full paragraph job description
don't make it easy to to sort through
inside you find a skill testing question
because so for mine will be like how
tell me how many YouTube subscribers I
have on my channel and put that in the
first sentence of your uh of your
application most people never even read
it
and so you're spending this is where
people waste time you're spending all
this time working on reading their
resume when they haven't spent any time
actually reading a job at and so if they
don't lead with the with the skill
testing question I don't look at their
resume
um and then we go through I don't do job
interviews there's no interview process
there's skill testing questions then we
start immediately going into actually
working together on a project that is
related to what we're gonna ultimately
hire them to work on
um anyway so it's it's a ends up being a
much faster process to get a right fit
and then you know it's a right fit as
opposed to hiring somebody you know if
you're hiring a bookkeeper for example
the interview process doesn't train the
right skill right like how well a
bookkeeper does in an interview isn't
reflective of how good a bookkeeper
they're going to be right maybe things
like that they show up on time but in
terms of actually testing their skill
set so I want to do trial jobs with
people anyway we could dive all into
that if you want but um
but much love to yelling out in the
group who came from upwork and most of
my team I think right now unless it has
to be somebody local is on upwork right
so you know if I'm I'm filming next week
with Kevin O'Leary in downtown Toronto
and I've got my camera guy coming with
me right I can't have uh I can't have
that run up work right but but my
editing team my research team my
analytics team my customer service team
uh most of administration team is on
upwork and so fantastic place to hire
um it works like an eBay system if you
haven't been on it where everybody gets
reviews so I I try to be a good employer
too and have good reviews on on my my
profile so that people want to apply
because it becomes important right at
some point when you build and scale you
can't do everything yourself and a lot
of times the the work that you can you
can Outsource it to somebody who has a
their cost of living is a lot low floor
as well so it's you don't necessarily
need to hire an American for everything
that you want to do some things might
require it but for the most part a lot
of things could be outsourced overseas
as well and people would rather
work from home and not have to drive to
some job that they hate right and and
hopefully you're a good boss and you're
doing something that is trying to change
the world and that people would want to
be a part of as opposed to just uh you
know another boring job in you know
whatever country people are coming from
so
anyway that's my quick rant on upwork
and again we can dive deeper if you'd
like okay next I'm going to jump to
Fiverr and uh
upwork I think about people who I want
to hire for long term I want I want to
you know I love yelling I want Elena to
never leave
but I wanted to never leave right it's
like it's an ongoing project I don't
like upwork for many tiny projects I go
to Fiverr for many tiny projects so here
are some examples of ones that I've done
some are now some of these are more
funny
um because most of my hiring doesn't
upwork but I made a video uh and I
wanted a Morgan Freeman voice so I I
hired somebody to record the video as
Morgan Freeman I then hired him to crank
call my agent in New York and also my
wife Nina remember that
I hired Morgan so I hired this guy to
make a video
I heard and he sounds exactly like
Morgan Freeman and and I hired him
before that to to call my agent Steve
and and pretend to be Morgan Freeman and
say that Evan Carmichael said to say hi
or something I forget what he said
I asked him to record it and so I got
the MP3 of him and then I had him uh and
my agent who's normally like this
hardcore New York uh you know take no
prisoner kind of guy was so soft and
gentle and it's like oh my goodness if
this is really Morgan
and then I had him call my wife Nina uh
I wish I still had the recording maybe I
do and and she's like who who's this
Morgan Freeman
I don't know who this is
he's like I'm an actor and anyway it's a
hilarious cop so you can also get some
fun stuff on there
um or my book the top 10 rules of
success we had little caricatures done
now I do a lot of cartoons on my social
right if you see my Instagram and
Linkedin and Twitter you'll see a lot of
the Evan cartoons but before that I I
didn't need I didn't feel like I had a
need for uh somebody to do cartoons
right now my illustrator is on upwork uh
and she's an ongoing role in my business
but when I did my top 10 rules of
success book I wanted a caricature for
each person that we had
um because putting putting pictures
inside books uh are sometimes it's hard
to see properly on the inside pages so
we have our characters and so I wanted
to hire somebody just for this one
project and so we paid whatever that was
Five Five Sixty seven to get
40 different caricatures done I think
inside the book and then I had some fun
ones right climb a coconut tree and find
a message there so that might be just to
recognize somebody on the team right
it's like happy one year anniversary and
it's like you get this video of this guy
climbing a coconut tree and inside would
be this custom message
um and then another one make a video
rant telling your recipient I had their
kid and I just did this to spoof a
friend
just something funny where she would she
made this video for my friend Louie to
say Louie I had your I had your love
child and you have to now take
responsibility for it
there's a lot of fun stuff on here I
guess this shows uh behind the scenes
kind of my sense of humor a little bit
but back to kind of serious business
upwork I think of ongoing projects for
people and Fiverr as one-off things that
you may need I wouldn't go to fiber for
ongoing work
um it's not the the nature of the
platform
uh so that's what I use for for hiring
really those two upwork by far number
one and then Fiverr for these one-offs
and if you're looking for some funny
just random stuff
um fiber is just super fun uh one other
thing that I could throw into the mix is
uh what's it called I'm blanking now a
cameo Cameo is a website where I haven't
used it but let me load it up here so
you can see cameo
I haven't hired anybody on here but if
you go to Cameo you can hire these
different people to say different things
and get personalized messages so uh some
of them are bigger than others Randy
Travis I love it DJ Drama Jesse itzler
you know soccer players uh wrestlers the
the Seinfeld Soup Nazi guy uh just tons
of people here let's say you wanted
Kevin Conrad Conroy uh best known as the
voice of the animated Batman since 1992.
so you know you pay 100 bucks and then
you see examples of what he's done so
birthday celebration special message ask
him a question some people use this
nefariously I don't recommend it so some
people bought Kevin O'Leary for example
to say Hey you gotta go watch Evan
tinsman he's the best guy I know about
how to overcome addiction right but
Kevin doesn't you know know Evan yet uh
and so I wouldn't use it that way but it
could be some fun fun content ideas or
find ways to surprise people on your
team I've been thinking about it as a
way for potentially a new series of like
hey tell me what your morning routine is
and and getting a whole bunch of people
to share the morning routine and then
splicing that into video but I haven't
pulled the trigger on
I'm super excited for today's topic guys
we're talking about content strategy I'm
going to share what I'm doing right now
in my business
but I'm also going to give you my
recommendations for what you should do
because I've got 30 people who help me
so it's a little different scale so
where you should start as well as where
I'm at right now okay content strategy
let's dive in now we're ready take a
deep breath don't get too overwhelmed
there's a lot of platforms let's talk
about them okay
content strategy so internally here's
how we divide the different types of
content that we create long form content
medium foam content short form content
and then pictures so long form is 10
minutes plus mediums one minute short 15
seconds and then and then pictures are
usually square pictures but you know
self-explanatory because the different
platforms
all have their own restrictions and I'm
going to share with you how long videos
need to be for different platforms
usually when we do pictures it's always
a square because that tends to work best
on every platform
um
just to set you up for your content
strategy okay so YouTube is the home
how do you create great content across
all the platforms it starts with having
a base and why I love YouTube as the
base is because one again it's the only
place where your content lives forever
so the videos that you make now in in a
week in a year in 10 years will still be
getting you views attention interest
traffic awareness uh I've I've had
videos that are five years old six years
old 10 years old still now getting today
still getting views today still getting
hundreds thousands of views today on on
a 10 year old video crazy and so if
you're on you're building a movement you
want it to last it's not just something
that's going to disappear tomorrow and
you're going to move on to something
else so YouTube is a great place to have
it have this memory have this archive
and continue to generate attention for
you
the second thing that's fantastic about
YouTube is it is the longest form so you
can upload videos that are I have eight
hour videos right you can have an hour
no problem you can have four hours no
problem you can have eight hours no
problem I don't know if you can do there
is a limit at some point I think it's
24. when I was doing my live streaming
uh I remember they cut us off now I
think it was 12 hours we went to New
York we were doing a live stream every
day and the max that they would let me
film for was 12 hours so
uh so there's a limit there but
hopefully you're not streaming or making
videos that are 12 hours long otherwise
you're good to go so you're thinking
YouTube as your long form YouTube as the
main place that you're posting 10 minute
plus videos and there's no there's no
Max right so if you want to make an
hour-long video or you want to record
your speech and put it up on YouTube
awesome that definitely works so let's
talk about the different platforms here
they are
I've color coded these okay and I
I wanted you to be able to have this so
that you can you can build your strategy
off of this you can build your team off
of this uh and you have it all in one
spot okay so you divide it into vertical
video horizontal video and square
pictures
let's start with square pictures that's
the easiest part so the idea is you take
your YouTube content and then you look
at what was the best thing that I said
you know what were the moments that
really stuck out what was the best quote
if you're making a video that's at least
10 minutes right or 15 minutes 20
minutes hopefully you said something
that's good in there
right some kind of quotable that you can
use in there that you can then turn into
pictures
and then we use those pictures is what
we'll do on our channels we'll use those
pictures and turn them into IG and
Facebook posts LinkedIn posts Twitter
post there's some nuances in in each of
these platforms that I'm not going to
get into today but I want to give you
the high level content strategy so
you're taking your videos here instead
of always trying to think what do I have
something to say the the problem that so
many entrepreneurs face when they're
creating content is you think you have
to create unique stuff for each one
and then look at how many options there
are and then it's overwhelming and then
you basically become a full-time social
media content person instead of actually
running your business and talking to
clients and and creating something
amazing so you use YouTube as your home
and then you pull off the different
pieces into all of these verticals So
when you say something great on YouTube
you think about what are the out of that
video that you made what are the three
to seven best things that you said best
quotables turn those into square
pictures and then post to these
platforms
makes sense uh now we go to horizontal
video so YouTube is a horizontal video
platform horizontal meaning we're going
this way we're filming this way instead
of vertical right vertical is you know
Instagram Tick Tock that kind of stuff
so horizontal videos LinkedIn you can
post a 10 minute video
Max Twitter you can do a two minute 20
video Instagram in the post you can do a
one minute video
and Facebook you can go up to uh 240
minutes so it's a lot of time on
Facebook uh initiative is funny when I
made this deck I didn't even have
Facebook on on the on the plan because
the Facebook organic hasn't been
fantastic but it still makes sense if
you're making videos that are uh from
YouTube you cut the best moments and
then you slice it up into these
different platforms now you don't have
to post 10 minutes if you made a two
minute video of the best part from your
YouTube video you can post it to
LinkedIn and you can post it to Twitter
and then you can take a highlight of
that and you can post it to your
Instagram and then you can take the
whole thing and post it to Facebook
so understanding you're using the same
video it all starts from YouTube use
that same video and then you're slicing
it up into just different edits
different cuts it requires a little bit
of editing skill or an Editor to help
you but you're not having to create you
know 20 pieces of content you every day
in front of the camera okay and then the
last one is vertical video so vertical
usually these are much shorter you've
got Tick Tock and IG stories Tick Tock
is up to a minute IG stories they're 15
seconds each but they could go up to a
minute so if you have a if you have a
one minute vertical video you can upload
that to your story and it'll chunk it up
into four times 15 seconds so these
you're thinking one minute videos IG
reels relatively new 15 seconds YouTube
stories 15 seconds some of these have
apis you can post to so we use a tool
called the gore pulse to help us post to
some of these some of them you can't uh
so it's Hit or Miss depending on some
things can be automated others you have
to do it manually from your phone or
have somebody on your team who you trust
to give access to be able to post from
their phone we talked about YouTube in
the past I want to bring back one graph
so like how do you decide what to pull
out
the answer is going to be in your
audience retention curve so this is an
example of an audience retention graph
it's not mine it's one that I found of a
of a 14 minute and 59 second video right
this is this is the video and it shows
you where people are falling off so
right away they lose a lot of people
right right away they lose a ton of
people and what we want to be looking
for is at one minute you're at 70 on its
retention and again if we want to dive
deep into YouTube strategies or look at
Nicole's channel that that could be a
whole topic on its own because winning
on YouTube is definitely going to be key
to having sustained momentum behind your
movement
so something weird happens here though
right look at how much it spikes so this
means at this point I don't know what
would we say this is 10 minutes 10
minutes into the video it goes from
let's call this 30 up to just over 50
percent
so 30 of the people who are watching
here now 50 of the people are watching
here
how does that happen well the either all
these people just fast forwarded to this
part or people who watched it rewound to
watch this part again either way this is
a big
Spike like whatever happens here is
amazing it's 10 minutes of just slowly
falling off and then boom something
happens here this is amazing so now we
got from a 10 minute Mark all the way up
to you know the 15 minute Mark for the
end of the video right so if you're
making
this is why you want to use this data
look at all the look at all these
different videos that we can we can pull
and make from this so if we're going to
pull pictures
whatever you said here is probably
really good right the one-liner two
liner three liners you can break up into
multiple picture posts you want to
likely take it from this moment right
here right what kept people's attention
what spiked their interest here to make
these videos here
if it's a 10 minute video this is Max
right it doesn't have to be 10 minutes
so for LinkedIn which is 10 minutes I'm
probably taking this last five minutes
I'm going to start here
and then go for the full five minutes
here because it's still
this is decent like it spikes but then
it falls down but then this is still
relatively flat which means you held
these people's attention they didn't
leave so if I'm doing LinkedIn I'm
looking at making a five minute LinkedIn
video
right then we go Twitter IG Facebook is
probably doing the same thing of a five
minute video Twitter and IG is one
minute and 220. so I'm looking at here
this one minute is what I'm gonna post
and then to Instagram and then these 220
is what I'm going to post to Twitter
so you're using the data this doesn't
even require somebody uh to to think too
much as they're going through it right
this is where it's easier to hand off to
somebody even part-time on the team to
say okay look at my video look at the
audience retention curve you spend a lot
of time crafting the perfect YouTube
video why because when you get the
YouTube video down look at everywhere
that it's going to go you're creating
content now across the entire internet
spreading your message and then all you
have to do is look at the data and say
okay well this is the part this is the
part that I want now we didn't have this
big spike I'd be looking at this being
the part because it's not up but it's
relatively flat which means you didn't
lose anybody's attention maybe starting
with something like this see that
there's a little Spike right there I I
look at what am I saying right here and
try to pull a quote from there this is
just super obvious that you know
whatever Happened Here of the 10 minute
Mark we want to be able to pull that in
so today's topic
how to reach your target audience I
think that's a great one I'm going to go
over some of the concepts in build to
serve but also elaborate and go a little
deeper on it because I think this is
super important as we're planning for
2021 you guys have a message you got a
purpose you know that your message can
impact people uh a lot of us aren't
doing the work yet so I want to see that
happen 2021 as well as the break this is
a good time to start planning your
content if you're gonna how you can
reach more people because we want to
explode out of 2021 out of the gate
because this is the year to make things
happen am I right we're going to make
things happen 2021 fam all right so how
to reach your audience so in built to
serve
I lay out three different paths to how
to reach your audience one is the
fastest way one is the medium way and
one is the longest way and so fast fast
to Freedom Alliance Partnerships and
becoming a thought leader fast faster
freedom is the fastest way alliances is
kind of the medium term and thought
leader is the one that takes the most
time and yields the biggest results so I
want you to play with the three of them
so that you get some traction happening
into your business fast to Freedom so
page 194 in uh build to serve I think
you guys all have your copy if you're in
this group welcome welcome
this is really important so you know
we're talking about social media we're
using all these different accounts to
help build our brand but it can feel
overwhelming it can feel like there's so
many accounts where do I focus where do
I spend my time uh you're also trying to
run a business it's not your goal to be
a full-time you know influencer so how
do you do it so Step One is the fast
pass to freedom and what that means is
one you create all of the accounts on
social media I don't want you posting
everywhere and worrying about being a
thought leader everywhere because that
can get overwhelming but I want you to
own the name so that nobody else can
take it
I want you to have your picture up there
and ideally the same one across a
different platform so people can
instantly recognize you and I want you
to have what I call the amazing 10-pack
of content
uh the amazing 10-pack of content is in
the book it's here you're who your why
your how your recipe breakdown this is
how did you do how did you get out of
the hole that you were in that's
something that's teachable so I want
three posts on that I want to see the
results two examples of the results and
then give me hope make me feel like I
can get out of this as well 10 pieces of
well craft content
and then that's it
no more posting content the fast pass to
Freedom
is just getting your your names
registered so nobody else can do it you
get your picture your bio and your 10
pieces of content
and then we start outreaching
if you're just in the content creation
game without doing the Outreach it takes
longer to start building the momentum
totally possible totally doable but if
you're not being consistent and you're
not getting the results and you feel
like giving up
we need to start doing more Outreach to
get more immediate traction and momentum
so I put Zane domain here let me show
you Zane's account and we can give him a
little bit of feedback just starting
here so just owning a different account
so this is Zayn's Instagram
okay
um one I would zoom in on the face a lot
more I want a headshot Zan uh because
again looking at it on mobile it's going
to be hard to see when it's super far
out uh the it's cut out super weird
so I would fix that uh because you're
dark and your suit is dark I wouldn't
have a black background I'd make it
something a lot brighter just like
you've got here you got the yellow and
the green and the blues and the Reds and
all this stuff so I would I would make
that brighter
so we have our picture right so we have
our Instagram account I'm not even
worried about all of this stuff yet
about posting the content right I'll
look at that IG live so cute we love
these two
there's Susie Susie in the house
um so we have our picture on the account
we have our bio I'm a certified
confidence coach author and entrepreneur
click the link below for coaching and
more info okay I would probably put in
here something about even DM me for
coaching
so I'm a certified confidence coach or I
help who I help entrepreneurs gain more
confidence uh so
something about being able to contact
you right the idea is the idea with the
fast passive freedom is
if your ideal client landed on your
profile page I want them to think about
hiring you
so of an ideal client someone who's
looking for confidence coaching landed
on Xander man's account I want them to
thank
I want to I want to reach out to Zane
so I would put something in here about
who you're targeting
so who do you help Zan if it's
entrepreneurs I help entrepreneurs gain
more confidence certify confidence coach
DM me if interested something like that
right here okay Zane's got a link tree
which is great so inside the link tree
you can have different uh different
links to different places this links to
his website this links to his YouTube
these are dead links then I don't know
if you knew that or not
so you click on Facebook it just goes to
facebook.com
[Laughter]
if you click on LinkedIn it just goes to
linkedin.com
and same thing with Twitter it goes to
twitter.com
so we want to be fixing that and there
should be something about coaching here
right so it was you know should be DME
for coaching but if you're going to do
it through a link tree there should be
something super obvious about how do I
get coaching
and this is a one-time thing that you
set up right it's it's high leverage
because we're assuming ideal clients are
coming to our page they're going to
click it we want to make it easy for
them so you're making a little more
difficult I mean you have the website
but the website here you know is coming
soon the confidence formula I don't know
what this is this looks like a book join
the list so how do we get coaching
you're a coach
you're a certified confidence coach I
need coaching how do I get coaching
right now I'm like clicking through I
don't know how to get coaching right so
that you want to make that super super
obvious
uh so his name here is Zane the man
Smith so then I go to Twitter and there
is no Zane demandsmith
so even if Zen has no interest in
Twitter yet and a lot of you I'm using
this as an example because I think a lot
of people are kind of in this boat
uh even if you have no interest in a
platform take the name so that nobody
else can take the name right so Zane the
man Smith is what he is on Instagram I
want him to be Zander man Smith
everywhere so when I go to Twitter
xandoman Smith this account doesn't
exist
I want you to own this name I want you
to upload your picture
I want you to put in your bio
and I want you to post 10 pieces of
content and I want everybody to do this
for all the platforms even if you have
no intention of being there one you own
it so that nobody else can take it and
two if somebody does reach out to you
you are listening can respond
so in this phase for all the other
platforms so again Twitter Jose may not
care about but he wants to at least be
on there because if somebody does tag
him he can respond and he can say thank
you
you're just recognizing your Champions
and you're listening that's all because
just because Zane doesn't care about
Twitter maybe some other people do care
about Twitter maybe his clients are on
Twitter maybe somebody's saying Zan is
amazing I just saw him on movement
makers you want to be able to say thank
you because even if you don't have an
audience that person might have an
audience so you get the name you put the
picture and then you're listening and
you're not going to get a thousand
notifications right I mean if you're
getting a thousand mentions every day
great you should be on that platform
right like if if one a month comes in
yeah that's great
but at least you're you know that that
one a month came in and you're paying
attention to them right so then you need
to get this account
um tick tock so Zane owns Tick Tock heys
and good jobs and the man Smith he's got
the account on Tick Tock uh no bio yet
those in no bio so we gotta we gotta fix
our bio and make it the same on all the
platforms
make it the same bio uh you're using a
different picture for some reason on
this one right so Zayn the man here is
this kind of zoomed in one you know no
tie Zander man here is different so both
I would put both as the exact same and
again zoom in on the face this one's
easier to see you because of the lighter
background so you're going to stand out
a lot more here compared to this one but
either way I want you to zoom in on this
and and put a put a put a bio in so for
every platform maybe you're not using
Tech talk yet maybe you don't care about
tech talk and this again not just for
Zan everybody here
you still get you should get Tick Tock
slash your name
just to own it because that might become
the big thing that in five years
everybody's all over and and then
there's some other Zan the man who took
your name
right
uh and so that's a simple setup across
all the different accounts
um see a couple chats coming in here so
Susie was asking do you recommend a link
to your account I like linktree I'm a
fan of linktree it allows you to put
multiple links inside each
um so you just don't have one link I
would still add DME because the the
biggest thing that Zane wants to do is
get coaching clients that should be his
number one step coaching clients and so
I want DME for coaching and then I want
inside his link tree something about
coaching here's how to get coaching with
me even if it's just an email address
for coaching not a website that takes me
to a book that isn't out yet that I can
save 50 on
right and that's okay we love you Zane
this is all love right
um so if you look at my
my I use Link tree
and if you look at mine as an example
uh I'm promoting my uh my YouTube
channel where we're doing a live show uh
every night and then my story the book
movement makers YouTube growth bootcamp
best life 30 right and a lot of the
posts that I'll put in I'll then say
check my check the link in the bio hey
if you're interested in Movie Makers
check the link in my bio so you could
also Zane could also be creating content
to say hey check the link in my bio for
coaching check the link in my bio for
whatever I wouldn't be trying to take
people away to a different platform so
when Xander was linking up
uh YouTube and then just random links to
Facebook Twitter and Linkedin right uh I
wouldn't try to send into another
platform I try to send them this is now
our funnel we want to try to get them to
move down the sequence with us to either
get their email address to get on a call
with them to get them to line as a
client right so what are the calls to
action here but the very basic one is
just coaching for Zayn that's what he
wants to do it should be super easy for
me to find out how to get coached
that's just an example of of using zans
right
uh in the book I go through how to make
these pieces of content you know who I
have recipe breakdown results examples
hope and then the key part here is
Outreach so you've got your picture
you've got your bio you've got the
account you've created your 10 pieces of
content and spent some good time
thinking about that and now it's
Outreach now we're not spending our time
making more content we're making we're
spending our time reaching out to people
we're spending our time commenting on
other posts so if I'm Zen instead of
making new content if he wants to help
coach entrepreneurs then I'm looking at
all the different entrepreneur accounts
so I'm looking at when Carmichael's
account I'm looking at garyvee's account
I'm looking at Grant cardone's account
I'm looking at Tom bilu's account I'm
looking all the people who are in my
space who you're kind of like
who that's your target audience and I
want to interact and answer questions
here's what's going to happen I post
something on my Instagram uh somebody
asked a question well we respond to
questions let's go someone else
um
garyvee right he'll answer a couple
questions but most of the feed is not
getting a personal reply so Gary posts
something to his Instagram somebody
asked a question
Gary's not responding Zan jumps in and
gives a great response not just like hey
thank you for your question or or fist
bump or an emoji but really gives value
to help that person
what are they going to do who's a Zan
the man guy I love his answer they're
gonna go click on his account and what
are they going to see they're gonna see
a picture they're gonna see a great bio
they're going to see a link to be able
to get coaching I'm going to see his 10
pack of content
that's why we have to have all that in
place because if they come and they
don't see that then they're not going to
take the next step
so we're spending our time instead of
making new content we're spending our
time on Outreach to try to get people to
visit our profile page you don't have to
say visit my profile page please they're
just going to do it
because you gave them so much value and
them as well as other people who are
paying attention to the chat
so always try to pick the most recent
post if you go a week ago on garyvee's
Instagram as an example you're not gonna
there's gonna be a lot of comments but
most people aren't engaging in that
anymore
so they're going to be on the new staff
so always go to the newest one give your
two cents and start helping people in
the comments they're gonna check out
your page and if you've done this work
of a great picture great bio and 10 pack
of content then you start building leads
for your business at a much faster rate
than just trying to create organic
content that will get you reach
this show on the road today we are going
to be talking about going live and
capturing content let's talk about
Instagram live so first one that we've
talked about in the past has been
coaching
so
the beautiful thing about doing live is
that it forces you to make content
what ends up happening to so many people
myself included when I was getting
started with content is you hesitate you
want to have the perfect script you
worried about the perfect lighting and
the microphone and all of these reasons
why you can't just make content but when
you're live you're live you're showing
up you're giving information and you
hope that it works out and it forces you
to create content
immediately it's fast you have stuff
going up is it going to be perfect no
but it's a great way to kind of get out
of your head and get through your fears
to actually make something for your
channel uh to start building your brand
and so the easiest place to start is
coaching
coaching your goal is to have people
come on they share a problem you help
them your goal is to liken this is an
example of a coaching call that I did on
Instagram your goal is to get somebody
to have a breakthrough
your goal is to get somebody emotional
to understand why they're at the point
where they're at right now and to help
them through it and for others to
experience that Journey with them right
the best parts of a lot of the seminars
that I go to
is the the the interventions or the live
coaching that people do
right the best part of the Brendan
burchard event that I was speaking at
was the the intervention even my own
right it's like hey you guys understand
this and the woman said that stood up
and said I don't quite get it okay let's
work through this me and you together in
front of the whole room right and go to
the Whiteboard and start
helping them solve the problem
those are always the best parts more
than the scripted versions and so your
goal is to help them understand why
they're at the point where they're at
get the Breakthrough and have everybody
experience that in the process so
coaching coaching needs to be a part of
your ongoing content strategy I want you
to get them emotion I want people you
know you look at the woman I'm coaching
here she's having an emotional time here
it doesn't mean that everybody needs to
cry on your session but I need them to
have have an aha moment
I need them to come in feeling confused
maybe hopeless and leave feeling like
they've got the strategies and the
belief those two things combined when
they leave you they've got the strategy
skill do something and the belief that
it's possible for them
it's my intention for everything even
here for you guys I'm trying to give you
the strategies on how to do it and the
belief that you can do it too
okay coaching
the second one is mentoring and we
haven't talked a lot about this for
Instagram lives but it's super valuable
think about the people who are in your
circle who are maybe part of your team
or people who you just really like and
doing it as an ongoing Series so the
difference between coaching and
mentoring at least for me is you know
the coaching is one-off
experience you guys are having somebody
comes in maybe you see them again maybe
you never see them again a lot of people
I've had on as coaching for Instagram
lives they just say hey pick me and I
pick them and I may never see them again
mentoring I see is more of an ongoing
relationship or this is somebody who you
want to help this is somebody who you
are invested into and want to see them
build and grow so this guy right here
his name is Kyle menko he's one of the
best uh League of Legends players in
North America and he also plays Teemo
which is the character that I play and I
sponsor him so I actually pay him every
month to coach me in League of Legends
and to to Splash my branding on his live
stream but part of that is we do a
mentoring session
every month where I I love this guy uh
huge heart wants to serve used to be uh
homeless and slept outside of a Walmart
in his car uh addicted to all sorts of
different uh alcohol
Etc and he turned his life around built
a full-time business off of playing
League of Legends and making YouTube
content and I want to see him
share his message to the world so I said
Kyle let's start a Regular Show where
I'm going to coach you on how to build
this business
and let's do it live on Instagram
so he joins in usually about once a
month and I help him
and again with coaching and mentoring
all you're doing is saying how you're
just showing up right I don't know what
he's going to bring when he comes I know
it's about YouTube I know it's about his
his twitch stream I know it's about
building his business but I don't know
what he's going to bring up this month
and and that's great you know it's not
some set presentation every single time
you actually get to sit there and help
somebody so there may be somebody in
your life I challenge you to think about
is there anybody in your life who you
could give some mentoring to
it may be somebody on your team who
you're building up and maybe uh a friend
or a niece or a nephew or somebody in
your circle who you really feel like
when you talk to them they take the
feedback and they do something with it
and now we're putting in a structured
way of
having that relationship both help them
more and also the world
I had another one where there were these
two guys and I was a guest on our
podcast and I love them so much and
they said hey we'd love to have you
Mentor Us in exchange for being featured
inside of our podcast
and I don't really even care about being
featured inside their podcast I never
paid attention if it was there or not
but I like the idea of having a
mentoring series and so we we made this
series that was once a month as well
where they came on I came on we did over
Instagram live and I helped them hey
guys what's up this month what do you
need help with where are you where are
you at what happened last month what's
great about the mentoring version is
it's like what happened last month
I said to do this where are we now and
what's going to happen in the next month
is that continuity
and it also shows you as a mentoring
coach
holding people's feet to the fire a
little bit
for some accountability as opposed to a
normal coaching session which would just
be here's what you should do okay let's
go but then you may never see them again
because this helps simulate what a
actual paid mentorship would look like
so if somebody is working with you this
is what they can expect
I don't sell coaching services but if I
did people get a sense of how I do it
right like oh that could be me that
could be me being coached by Evan and
him pushing me to do better right I may
not want it to be live for everybody but
that's great that's why you have your
paid program think of somebody in your
life who you like working with who you
like mentoring and guiding and whenever
you're with them you give them advice
they take it and then they're cut
they're updating you and just making
this a more formal process
put it in the calendar instead of
meeting them by chance once every six
months now you're having a monthly
meeting with them and you're making it
public you can't they may not be able to
share everything everything public
but they can share a lot and in that
process a lot of people can learn as
well
so mentoring coaching mentoring
next is interviews so I strongly
strongly strongly strongly push every
interview for people who want to come on
my channel to do an Instagram live
it's my number one this is Wim Hof so if
you guys know whim uh Wim hop The Iceman
he's crazy he's amazing uh cold cold
bars breathing techniques
um he's been on the show a couple times
I did his I did his Workshop here in
Toronto we filmed it we've done a couple
other videos now he's doing another PR
tour and instead of going YouTube first
we did Instagram
Kevin O'Leary same thing Shark Tank
right promoting
uh promoting his new Investments that
he's made
same thing it's going to go to YouTube
but we start off on Instagram
Dean graziosi same thing right so this
became a YouTube video here's the
YouTube video right we turn it into you
can see the thumbnail that's he's
wearing the same thing he's in the that
actual room we take the the thumbnail
from the actual video and we turn it we
just have to flip it to go horizontal so
every time we're doing Outreach to do
interviews or people are coming to me to
say hey can I be on your Channel
then it's Instagram first ideally not
everybody says yes Seth Godin said no
Seth go ahead and said no let's do it as
a zoom like okay
you're the boss let's see what is the
zoom everybody else though has said yes
so
um there's a 60 chance we're gonna be
doing Tony Robbins next week
we're doing uh Deepak Chopra coming up
we're doing uh Marie forleo coming up uh
we've got a bunch of people coming up
that are going to be some pretty
exciting interviews and I'm defaulting
to Instagram live to have them on
and then turn into YouTube videos and
put it on my channel
what's so great about this and I've
talked about it before but but I really
want to pound that message home is when
you go live with somebody it tells both
of your audiences that you're live
so
I discovered that
maybe a week before my last Tony Robbins
interview
and I was kicking myself to say this
should have been an Instagram live
because if we did an Instagram live his
entire audience would be notified that
I'm live with him as well
so when you're interviewing people now
you may not be at the point yet where
you're interviewing
Dean and Tony and Deepak and these
people that's fine but if there's
somebody who you would like to interview
who might be at a smaller level who
still has a bigger audience than you
default to making it on Instagram live
because when you're live together Their
audience gets notified and then they
learn about you
so whoever you know we have a list of
100 people
and I've got a guy named Bo who helps me
do all of the Outreach to get people on
the show and I give them a list of 100
people
you can make your own list of 100 people
and you can put some big names on there
uh like big big crazy names right I mean
I have Elon Musk on my list and Oprah
Winfrey on the list and Kanye West on
the list and you know all those people
and and we're working towards that it's
a long crazy process to get those people
on because they don't do this kind of
stuff but then also people further down
you could build your own list where
you've got the 10 10 of people who are
The Impossibles but it's good to have
that ambition drive to get them and then
the others are people who you're working
towards actually potentially getting
people who have a mission a message that
you want to help share
and that you're working towards bringing
them on your show I don't like it as an
only strategy for you guys I don't want
you only to be doing interviews because
I want you to be the thought leader as
well I want you to be the coach as well
I want people to hear your voice and
your opinions and what you've got to say
so you're not just what I call the Larry
King right just the person asking the
questions
but as part of a Content mix it's great
and as a way to hack other people's
audiences it's fantastic
so look at some of the people who have a
bigger audience than you who you
genuinely care about and like them and
would love to have a chance to interview
them and and bring them on
invite them invite them to join
especially when they're talking about a
new book you know Tony right now uh has
a new program that he has coming up a
new free initiative he's launching and
so he's trying to get attention on it uh
Jeremy on my team who does the YouTube
Consulting loves Ray dalio Ray Daley
wrote the book principles he loves Ray
dalio
and uh
Ray dalio is super recluse and doesn't
do a lot of stuff he did a whole bunch
of media around principles now he's
geared up that was what three years ago
he's geared up to do a new launch for a
new book that he's doing so Now's the
Time like Jeremy if you want to talk to
Ray now is the time to do it
people may not talk to you like even for
guys like Dean I don't call up Dean and
say Hey Dean how long was this video 26
minutes do you have 26 minutes to just
chat
you know Tony Robbins is not hey Tony
you got you got half an hour just to to
chill right this doesn't happen but when
it's when it's public people are much
more likely to say yes
and so it's something to think about for
your own content strategy for sure if
you want to watch the full 85 minute
version of this video and train with me
live twice a month to build your online
audience make money from it and use it
to change the world you have to join my
movement makers program for more
information click the link right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see